we will now go through a beautiful
example in which we approach the same
question in a number of different ways
and see that by reasoning based on the
intuitive properties of a Poisson
process we can arrive quickly to the
right answer the problem is as follows
we have three light bulbs and each light
bulb is being lit at time 0 it starts
working and the light bulb lasts for a
certain amount of time which is random
so this light bulb at last so long this
one lasts so long this one lasts that
long the lifetime of a light bulb the
time until it burns out will be a random
variable and we make the following
assumptions the lifetimes of the three
light bulbs which we denote by x y and z
will be independent random variables
each of which is an exponential random
variable with the parameter lambda were
interested in the question of
calculating the expected time until a
light bulb burns out for the first time
so in this picture the light bulb that
burned out first is this second light
bulb and this quantity is the time until
the first burn out how do we calculate
this quantity the time until the first
light bulb burns out is the minimum of
the times at which each one of them
burns out so we're interested in the
expected value of this quantity it's a
random variable which is a function of
three random variables how do we
calculate the expected value of a
function of random variables we can use
the expected value rule let us take the
function of interest which is the
minimum of three numbers then we need to
multiply by the joint PDF of these three
random variables XY and Z now because
these three random variables are
independent the joint PDF is the product
of their individual PDFs which are all
exponential and so we obtained this
expression for the joint PDF and we need
to integrate this over all x y&z
so it's going to be an integral that
goes for each one of the three variables
from 0 to infinity and here we have DX
dy DZ so this is one approach that can
give us the answer if you're able to
manipulate and keep track of everything
that happens in this three-dimensional
integral but this is too tedious and
this is not a good way to go let us try
to think of an alternative way can we
figure out the distribution of this
random variable it's a function of three
random variables so in some sense it's a
derived distribution problem so we can
try to calculate the cumulative
distribution function of the minimum of
the three so for the cumulative we would
be looking at the probability that the
minimum of these three random variables
is less than or equal to a certain
number it turns out that the
calculations are a little faster if we
look at the probability that this is
larger than or equal to a certain number
what is this event the minimum is larger
than or equal to T if and only if all
three of them are larger than or equal
to T so the probability of this event is
the same as the probability that X is
larger than or equal to T y larger than
or equal to T and Z larger than or equal
to T but now x y&z are independent so we
need to multiply the probability that X
is larger than or equal to T which for
an exponential random variable is e to
the minus lambda t then the probability
of the second event which is again e to
the minus lambda T and finally the
probability of the third event which is
again e to the minus lambda T which is e
to the minus 3 lambda T now we look at
this expression for the probability that
the random variable is larger than or
equal to T and recognize that this is
the expression that we have when we have
an exponential random variable with
parameter equal
two three lambda if you want to do it
formally subtract this quantity from one
to find the CDF take the derivative and
you will find an exponential PDF so the
conclusion is that this random variable
is exponential with parameter three
lambda and since it's an exponential
with parameter three lambda then we know
what the expected value is it is going
to be one over three lambda and this is
the answer to the question that you were
interested in now the fact that this is
an exponential random variable but with
a different parameter is a pretty clean
fact and so it should have a good
explanation let us now try to think
about a good explanation for this fact
whenever we deal with an exponential
random variable one way of thinking
about it is that this exponential random
variable is the first time in a Poisson
process so imagine that there is a
Poisson process that runs forever and X
is the first arrival time for this light
bulb we can think the same way and since
x and y are assumed to be independent we
can assume that here we have an
independent Poisson process independent
from the first one it has its own
arrival times and Y is the first arrival
time in this Poisson process and finally
we have a third independent Poisson
process and the random variable Z is the
first arrival time in that Poisson
process so XY and z are interpreted as
first arrivals in three independent
Poisson processes now let us take these
three Poisson processes and merge them
if we merge these three processes
what we obtain is a merged process which
is Poisson with parameter equal to the
sum of the rates or parameters of each
one of the processes so it's a Poisson
process with parameter 3 lambda now how
can we interpret the random variable of
interest the first Burnout
in terms of the merged process so the
merged process has an arrival whenever
one of those three processes has an
arrival the first arrival in the merged
process will happen the first time that
one of these three processes is going to
have an arrival therefore we can
interpret the random variable of
interest the first burnout time as the
first arrival time in a merged process
but now the merged process is Poisson
with parameter three lambda therefore
this random variable is going to be an
exponential random variable with
parameter three lambda and from this we
also obtain the expected value of that
random variable the beauty of this last
approach for coming up with the answer
by reasoning in terms of merged Poisson
processes is that we didn't have to do
any calculations at all just use the
intuitive understanding of Poisson
processes and especially the
interpretation of an exponential random
variable as the first arrival time in a
Poisson process let us now try to solve
a somewhat harder problem let us try to
calculate the expected time until all
light bulbs burn out so one light bulb
will burn out then another one will burn
out and finally the third one will burn
out we want to find the expected time
until this happens once more we will be
thinking of these burn out times as the
first arrival times in Poisson processes
the total time until the third burnout
can be split into different periods
there is a time until one light bulb
burns out and the expected value of this
period here is going to be one over
three lambda what happens at this time
the second light bulb has burned out so
we can forget about it take it out of
the picture
we have two light bulbs let us look at
the time it will take until one of these
two light bulbs burns out so we're
interested in this period of time
now the Poisson process starts fresh at
this time after this time whatever
happens is just an ordinary Poisson
process as if it was starting at this
time so this is going to be an
exponential random variable starting
from this time and this is going to be
another exponential random variable so
the time until the next light bulb burns
out in this case is going to be the
minimum of two exponential random
variables we can think again about
merging these two Poisson processes to
obtain a Poisson process with total rate
two lambda and the time until one of
these two burns out is going to be the
first arrival time in that merged
process and so the expected time until
the first arrival of the merged process
is going to be one over two lambda and
finally once this burned out has
happened we can forget about this light
bulb we're left just with one light bulb
and starting from here we wait until
that light bulb burns out once more
because of the fresh start property of
the Poisson process starting from here
until it burns out is going to be a
random variable which is an exponential
random variable and in this case an
exponential random variable with rate
just lambda and by adding these three
quantities we get the expected time
until all three have burned out this is
a problem that would have been quite
hard to solve in a more analytical way
we're dealing with a random variable
which is now the maximum of XY and Z and
the distribution of this random variable
is not so simple to write down so it
that would not be a very good approach
for going about this problem but we
managed to find the expected value
this random variable without having to
write down its distribution by breaking
this random variable into a sum of three
particular random variables each of
which had a nice intuitive
interpretation and that was the key to
the solution of this problem